horror is all about surprise and these
moments including an accidental
electrocution a cannibal's connection to
a bloodsucker and a creepy inside joke
surprised everyone
at the conclusion of the classic 1996
slasher scream we finally learn who's
behind the mask of the ghostface killer
that's been terrorizing the local teens
of woodsboro it turns out there wasn't
just one knife-wielding maniac but two
billy the bad boy boyfriend of heroin
sydney and agent of chaos stew unlike
billy stu doesn't have a personal
vendetta or a tragic dark past so when
this deadly duo enact the final step of
their plan by stabbing each other to
make it appear as though sydney's dad
attacked them stu doesn't exactly take
it very well he babbles and hurls
obscenities with the shock of a child
who has just learned what consequences
are amidst the chaos sydney slips away
calls the cops and proceeds to
antagonize her assailants over the phone
a frustrated billy then throws the phone
across the room and to hit stu in the
head
screenwriter kevin williamson revealed
on the movie's blu-ray commentary that
matthew lillard improvised a huge chunk
of his lines including the one in
response to being hit with the phone in
fact this whole moment was unplanned as
skeet ulrich was supposed to throw the
phone at the kitchen counter but it
slipped out of his hands that were
covered in fake blood so when he
accidentally hit his co-star instead
lillard promptly retorted in character
when aspiring fbi agent clarice staling
pays a visit to imprison serial killer
hannibal lecter she learns the truth
about him via a vivid anecdote from the
man himself about his encounter with a
census taker
i ate his liver with some fava beans and
a nice chianti
anthony hopkins delivery as lecture is
inhumane and terrifyingly visceral it's
a perfectly creepy thing for a madman
like hannibal and a disturbing
demonstration of vulgarity the slurping
noise that he makes wasn't actually in
the silence of the lam's screenplay but
was instead something the actor added in
at the last minute in a 2016 interview
with radio times he revealed i don't
know why but i've always known what
scares people when i was a kid i'd tell
the girls around the streets the story
about dracula he then reproduced
lecture's legendary hiss and added that
that runs screaming away
jack nicholson's performance as a writer
losing his mind in 1980s to shining is
filled with plenty of unforgettable
moments there are the quiet opening
scenes when his strange smile belies his
simmering insanity then there are
sequences when the overlook hotel begins
to seduce and increasingly boost up jack
torrance thereby alienating him from
reality itself and then there's of
course a film's final act when he tears
through anyone foolish enough to wind up
on the pointy end of his axe and the
latter features one particularly
memorable improvised moment while jack's
wife wendy cowers in the bathroom he
hacks away at the feeble door with
reckless abandon after creating a
suitable crack he peers through the
porthole and maniacally proclaims
here's johnny
that line doesn't appear in either
stephen king's novel or the film's
screenplay as it was instead ad-libbed
by nicholson maybe director stanley
kubrick's infamously exhaustive takes
drove nicholson over the deep end or
maybe he's just a really big fan of late
night host johnny carson either way it's
a terrifying moment
just imagine you're out on a shark hunt
and when you least expect it your prey
emerges from the ocean's deaths summoned
by all that delicious chum you've been
dumping into the water how would you
respond before this moment happens in
1975's jaws police chief martin brody
has seen the shark before but only in
mere glimpses but now with the beast
just feet from his face he has a real
sense of what he and his men are up
against
you're gonna need a bigger boat
as joe's screenwriter cole gottlieb
recalled to the hollywood reporter in
2016 brody's famous utterance wasn't a
scripted line so much as it was an
in-joke among the filmmakers the movie
shoot suffered from numerous
difficulties like producers refusing to
spend money on a bigger support boat to
steady the barge carrying all of the
equipment as gottlieb explained it
became a catchphrase for any time
anything went wrong if lunch was late or
the swells were rocking the camera
someone would say you're gonna need a
bigger boat so roy scheider ad-lib the
line at various points throughout the
shoot to try to get this inside gag into
the final cut his persistence ultimately
paid off in the scene when brody gets up
close and personal with the great white
as gottlieb remembered it was so
appropriate and so real and it came at
the right moment
the chess bursts are seen in the 1979
sci-fi horror classic alien is an
absolute nightmare while the crew of the
nostromo enjoys a pleasant crew
breakfast it's clear that something
terrible is about to happen sure
executive officer kane says he feels
great but he recently had an alien
horseshoe crab glued to his face so it's
hardly surprising that the incubating
baby alien cracked its way through his
fragile human ribs and ripped his way
through his guts then it flashes its
pearly whites before zipping off into
the air ducts to fully mature into the
monstrous killer that will make the crew
members lives a living hell but what
really sells this scene are the crew's
reactions they look genuinely horrified
and that's because they were john hurt
was the only actor who knew what was
going to happen mainly because he was
outfitted with a prosthetic chest for
the real animal organs and the
compressed blood machine but the rest of
the cast was ushered offset while herd
was strapped in so that they could be
kept totally in the dark when they
leaned in close over hurts fake torso
they got an unexpected face full of
explosive viscera sometimes to make
horror movie history you have to break a
few ribs
most of the entries on this list feature
human ingenuity but this one is more
about human error as revealed in the
making of documentary never sleep again
the elm street legacy the scene in
1984's a nightmare on elm street in
which his snoozing glenn lance is sucked
through his bed didn't exactly go as
planned if you've seen it you surely
remember the geyser of blood that
emerges from the bed after glenn gets
sucked in and then gravity basically
stops working as the blood begins to
slush from wall to wall like a crimson
tide perfectly capturing the nightmare
logic of play with freddy krueger but
filming the scene was a nightmare into
itself it was shot in a rotating room
that was flipped upside down the mission
was simple pour fake blood into a hole
and film it the first problem was that
the red liquid was poured onto a lamp
which electrocuted a crew member on top
of that the now electrified blood caused
the room to roll all the way over
fortunately though nobody was seriously
injured and the filmmakers were left
with a trippier sequence than they'd
expected
no one was hurt we got the shot
possessed preteen reagan mcneil goes
through hell over the course of the 1973
classic the exorcist and the most
hellish moment is probably when she
projectile vomit split pea soup onto
father keras naturally enough he reacts
by gasping for breath and looking
appropriately disgusted but if you look
really closely you can also detect a
hint of uncharacteristic anger on the
usually even-tempered priest this is
because jason miller the actor who
played him wasn't clued into what
exactly was going to happen in the bbc
documentary the fear of god 25 years of
the exorcist the movie's head of special
effects revealed that he was all set up
to have the vomit hit miller in the
chest a scripted and rehearsed but
delays in setting up the scene led to
the vomit getting cold so the trajectory
of the rig was changed and tilted it up
towards miller's face and his unscripted
reaction made it into the final cut
1996's from dusk till dawn is what you
get when you throw vampires westerns and
siege thrillers all together in a
blender one scene finds two bad brothers
played by george clooney and quentin
tarantino in a lavish watering hole
called the titty twister awaiting the
arrival of a partner in crime soon after
the duo arrive a stripper by the name of
santanaco pandemonium performs a
snakedance striptease routine this is
before the brothers discover that this
bar in the middle of nowhere is also an
ancient aztec haunt for a coven of
bloodsuckers so at least the dance is an
enjoyable perk to their supposedly calm
rendezvous santanaco was an early role
for salma hayek in a 2017 interview with
yahoo she admitted that she has very few
memories of filming the striptease scene
because as she put it it had to go on
trance to do the dance this was all a
matter of the actress overcoming her
fear of snakes as she further explained
there was no choreography it was
improvised because you can't choreograph
a snake we don't know what she's going
to do
kneel and worship at the feet of
santanico pandemonium the blair witch
project wasn't the first found footage
horror film but it's almost surely the
most influential filmed on commercially
available camera equipment a big part of
what makes blair witch so scary is its
commitment to realism it really feels
like we've stumbled across tapes
recording an ill-fated documentary crew
and a big part of how directors eduardo
sanchez and daniel myrick captured that
realistic vibe was by having almost the
entire film be improvised as relayed in
an oral history for vice celebrating
blair witch's 20th anniversary the
film's cast of three inexperienced
non-union actors were set loose in the
maryland wilderness to basically fend
for themselves they only had one hazy
sense of anything resembling a plan
every night at the campsite each actor
would be given a film canister and a
milk crate with top secret instructions
that they weren't allowed to share with
each other for instance when joshua
leonard mysteriously vanished in the
middle of the night his castmates had no
idea that was going to happen as the
actors tell it they would have been
genuinely terrified if they weren't so
damp cold and exhausted from actually
camping while making a film
a 1978 remake of a 50s b movie the
philip kaufman directed invasion of the
body snatchers spins a terrifying yarn
about spores from outer space that
quietly spread carbon copies of human
beings to take over the world in the
film's final moments it appears that
donald sutherland's matthew has somehow
managed to evade the swarm of alien
clones which is weird because it seems
like he'd been cornered but now here he
is going peacefully about his day maybe
he's found a way to fly under the radar
and trick the aliens that's what
veronica writes nancy hopes anyway when
she sees her old friend but then
matthew's jaw spills open and his eyes
peeled wide as he screamed to the
signature accusatory shriek of an alien
clone nancy is a gas as are the rest of
us
[Applause]
and so was cartwright as it turns out as
kaufman explained to the hollywood
reporter in 2018 while sutherland was
clued into this dire version for the
film's ending cartwright was left in the
dark as the director explained i don't
remember that we even told veronica
until donald turned and did that shriek
korfman's desire was to make an ending
that would be truly horrific which is
why he didn't share it with anyone not
even the studio executives the result
was ultimately quite uncanny as
cartwright looks genuinely shocked and
terrified that's perfectly
understandable though because if you
were suddenly faced with a shrieking
donald sutherland you might be pretty
terrified too
[Music]